have your other piece of paper in your
book they're nearby because I'd love you
to also be able to write a few things
and not necessarily ruin the page you
get a hand in because like I said if you
didn't catch it before this page that
you've got in front of you you will hand
in at the end of this lesson you'll see
what you're gonna use it for now the
kind of puzzle that I'm going to teach
you about today as the name as the page
suggests is called a loop okay now let
me show you what a loop looks like you
don't need to draw this I just wanted to
show you what it would mean a loop is
well let's just make one up let's do
something like this
can you see that that missile yep so
this would be a completed loop as the
name suggests you have to have one line
that goes all the round forms and loops
there are no loose ends it never
connects back to itself it doesn't cross
over sorry it doesn't cross over itself
it does kick back to itself you have one
loop just one on the entire board so
this might be one or you could have
something like whoops let's delete the
whole thing there one fight
you could have something like this that
would still be a loop you don't have to
fill up every single thing what you're
trying to do is find what is the loop
that fits the particular board that
you've got so now have a look over at
this one in the top left-hand corner
pick up your pin and I'm going to show
you how to complete a loop based on the
clues that get given to you so you got
these numbers right the number indicates
and this might be worth writing down at
the top of your page the number
indicates how many lines are around that
space let me say that again the number
indicates how many lines I should say
intervals actually are around that
particular space so for example see this
spot right in the middle here okay you
can see there's four spaces where you
could connect the dots there's four
spaces where you could two of them are
connected so it might be here and here
or or here in fear and two or not okay
so when we finish this loop two of the
lines of join and two won't have a look
at the zero in the top left what does
that tell you there's no lines or in a
perfect way so in fact that's going to
be the first way I'm going to suggest
that you start to help me solve this
right
because I know and we know together
there can't be any loans there you might
want to put some crosses there to
indicate you're not allowed to go there
going there would mean that you have
lines around there so it wouldn't
fulfill the zero okay and once you've
done that you can start to look at the
rest of the puzzle and the rest of the
cruising pace it together
for example let me use a different color
here I'm gonna tell you right now if
this is true then you can guarantee
there will not be a line there now I
wonder if anyone can work out why look
carefully at what we've got
can anyone suggest okay I'm gonna pause
me because I think rashan's hand went up
first what do you think Krisha very good
so and hearing was that what you were
thinking similar lines yeah so just you
don't have to put this in because
obviously it's wrong suppose I did put a
line there right remember it's a loop so
there are no loose ends right have a
look at the left-hand part of that
where's it going to go
it can't go here because we said you
know loud I can't go here either so
therefore you're kind of at a dead end
so that's how I know let's just undo all
that you can't possibly go here in the
same way you can't possibly go here
right now let's have a think we're gonna
top right hand corner there's a three
over there so it's going to look
something like this
either like that or like that or like
that or like that do you agree it's got
to be one of those because that's three
lines okay which do you think it will be
are there any that we can like eliminate
that they're impossible you can't have
that
oh yeah well you reckon is oh hold on
just hit pause let me let me name them
let's call this one a B C and D which
one you talking about D okay why not
very good that's right and then also if
there were four lines number one it
doesn't obey the three number two what
are you going to do all the rest over
here remember I mentioned there's one
loop that goes all the way through if I
went there it's closed it's finished
does that make sense so let me keep
pause we've already just said it can't
be this one I wonder if you can work out
which one it should be let me give you
30 seconds to try and work it out
yourself and then we'll come together
and have a thing I'll give you a second
to try and work it out put your hand out
if you think you've worked out which one
it is
I'll give you another ten seconds I want
to see if everyone can get their hand up
I can't you knock which one do reckon is
a B I'll say B we reckon agrees with e
note yeah okay so it let's let's all
draw in what that should look like so we
think it looks like this can I ask how
did you work out that it had to be baby
Chaka
okay so we can go further down here
that's good though I should point out
even though you can do something that
doesn't mean you have to for example can
anyone tell me how did you get rid of a
a is an easy one to exclude you know you
can't say why not yeah yeah very good
yeah you again you have those dead ends
that can't go anywhere
okay so once you've got that as vishakha
suggested you know you're gonna have to
go down probably otherwise you have a
dead end and you can start to see how
you fill in the rest of the puzzle okay
so can I give you a couple minutes try
and do those first to see if you can
complete the loop check with someone
else nearby if you think you've got both
those answers I'll give you a minute to
do that and then I'll show you what the
great ones are about what I have a look
how confident are you that that's
correct
like scale of one to ten one being look
I just guessed ten being like I know
like I'm very confident you're not
confident so here you go tell me tell me
why ah
so this three tick this to tick this to
this to this three all fine but this one
does have two lines on either side so
something's gone wrong done it well that
look at it again carefully look at all
the clues okay so let's have a look
you've got the three that's good you've
got the two has two now these two in the
middle does it have to be the round but
that's also attached to this right so
there's three lines around this one yeah
I see that
does that make sense now yours is closer
because I noticed you've got the three
you've got the - you got that - you got
this - but there's a couple of issues
here aren't there look at that one and
that one
what's happened yeah so you're close
you're close you're closer than this but
that you're both you're both having
trouble everything I see you've made
some adjustments to my numbers can you
do with the numbers that are there why
don't you stop me this one it's fresh
what do you got
nicely done so are you confident that
they're all perfect yes okay good now
I've got a question for both of you I'm
going to tell everyone a minute but you
notice that the two gray ones they're
very similar very very similar but
there's a tick on one and a cross on the
other I want you to see if you can work
out what the tick in the cross means
well I want you to think about it I
don't think it means something a little
more than that you gotta see does it fit
you can go through every number you can
check right see you right
yes one yes nice to know do the second
one I'm not gonna tell you in a start on
that one all right good
okay okay
so can I ask for everyone's attention
again please sorry
spoilers I'm gonna show you the answer
now you're gonna get an L shape like
this it's actually a backwards L shape
so this is the shape you should have
gotten this is the loop okay
now some of you are quite close you
might have gotten for example a common
one I saw a common mistake I saw looks
something like this I think quite a few
people had it got this one can someone
tell me because very close to being
right like for example that two looks
good that two looks good that three
looks good lots of its right what's the
issue Aditya what do you think yeah this
one here have a look at how many lines
around it how many lines are in it too
and in fact it's the same with this guy
right so that's how you can know this is
very important maybe write this down the
top for me I ran out of space loops are
unique can you write that for me loops
are unique so when you have a look at
the clues there is only one loop that
actually fits all of them and that's a
very important piece of information I
think from memory what's this one I
actually can't I think there's a line
straight up and down I think then I'm
wondering or can someone help me out
this is this go to the is it go this way
and down like that oh that's right it's
like this one isn't it
today I remember it right I'm just doing
off the top my head yes okay wonderful
all right now here's where it gets
really interesting that was just the
warmup solving loops is actually very
easy it's when you are making loops that
things get much more fascinating so have
a look at these two gray ones okay now
what do you notice what's the first
thing that you notice this different
let's just look at the first one what's
different about this one compared to the
two loops above what do you see this
different yeah there are fewer clues
right I've taken away three numbers okay
now my question to you is can we still
solve it the answer is we can right
let's just start to do it together and
for example if you haven't already
worked out zeros are a nice place to
start because they give you certainty
right so I'm quickly going to put in a
few spots I know I can't go like that
okay because you have those zeros those
X's that are close to the threes that
also tells you a lot of information
right what are you gonna have over here
how would you describe it it's kind of
like a like a C right a C facing that
way so you know you're gonna have this
over here you also know you're gonna
have a arm like an N on the top does
that make sense like so okay where's
that one gonna go where does it have to
go it has to go to the right okay
now at that point can I go up I can't
because then I'd have a dead end so
you've got to go down and fairly quickly
you'll realize oh alright
this is the only way that you can finish
are you content with that does it fit
all the chords you've got now ah now
this is this is interesting right
there's a tick here because this is
unique remember I said loops are unique
have a look down at this one it's almost
identical what's the difference you have
just removed that - do you see that now
we can start off the way that we did
before so I'm gonna put all those X's
there right I'm gonna put this this C
that you suggested over here and this
scalp here that has to go there that has
to go there but now now things are
different
right because unlike in the previous
situation there's actually more than one
way to complete this loop do you agree I
could definitely do it the way I did
before but I could just do that
someone told me a different way to do
this one Louise yep-yep left and not
very good does this fit all my clues it
does right now what this means is
because I could do this or I could have
done the previous solution which looks
like this this loop is not unique does
that make sense so you actually can't
solve this one you can't know like is it
this one is it that one okay so now
here's the real task we're actually
going to do today and it's a fun open
task because it's an infinite number of
solutions okay you're going to use those
blank spots over on the right to make
your own loops to design your own loops
and here are the questions I want to ask
of you and the loops that you create can
you remove any clear remove any number
and still leave the loop solvable so
there's only a single unique solution
can you get rid of any two codes can you
get rid of in three does it matter which
clue you remove what's the smallest
number of course a minute anomaly you
solve a loop of this size if you only
get like two clues or three is that
possible
okay so and can you build a loop that
requires exactly four quiz to solve so
this piece of paper is going to have
your loops on it that you submit to me
it'll just have the numbers because then
we can work out don't give us the
answers but use your book because you
might well the first few times I did it
I got it wrong a bunch of times as you
explore it as you have a play okay so
here's the task this is what you'll
submit to us at the end of lesson have a
play in your own books make some dots
you can make them all this size and this
is a nice medium size if you make it
smaller it's quite boring if you make it
bigger it gets really hard how they go
see how far you can get all right off
you go